so we had corporal punishment in
boarding school which is you know just
very physical stuff so yeah we had to
take our pants off and somebody take a
hockey stick and like hit us on our ass
and then you do that in a line and then
go back to the back of the line and I
was the kid who wouldn't shut the hell
up during the you know the punishment
yeah
wasn't that hard you know and we had
something called a slap Circle all right
so it's it's all your friends you stand
in a circle with each other right and
then you slap each other of course
karmically your best friend will be
standing right next to you right and so
what will happen is you give your best
friend like a light sort of a touch and
then the senior will come and slap the
out of you right so now you go to
your best friend turn on him completely
and smack the out of your best
friend he gets angrier hits the next guy
hits the next guy they do three rounds
and then they reverse the order oh so
the guy with the Revenge you get revenge
after that